ce n'était pas la télé je pourrais te je
pourrais être dragués toi tu es marié
tester majesty sérieuse alors soit il
par la télé on parlait de ton actu tu
crois non on n'en parlerait pas en fait
ce n'était pas ça n'était pas été pas
donc là on va en parler parce qu'on
habite nantes est ce que tu t'intéresses
à tout ce que je fais dans tu me
donnerait alors non je reviens bien sûr
en arrivant je pense que je te
demanderai de trois questions
on me donnait une contre je crois que
alex reeves
je crois que les mecs ils ont décidé oui
mais qu'est ce que ça va intéresser le
public au spectacle
ouais tu vas voir qu'après cette
émission pour décor il va intéresser le
public
[Applaudissements]
et jamel c'est repoussé non mais non
nettoie fait comme si de rien n'était
vous continuez vos émissions allez-y on
y va occasionner un problème il n'a pas
un caméra wi catherine je pense que ma
veste et qu'il l'a pas fait nous
comptons sur lui rendent bien
il revient à tanis téloche de triche
times c'est le mec de blanc dit tu sais
pas je suis désolé s'est quittés potes
qui sont avec toi là ddd est repris de
justesse et social
[Applaudissements]
quand il ya deux ans alors michel thioub
à michel qui va tourner dans [ __ ]
gurdon lui avec d'armand dutronc dany
boon a exactement mais je crois qu'on va
beaucoup s'amuser et dany boon tu l'as
tu l'as vu ces temps-ci non la dernière
fois que je les ai vus j'ai pas vu sa
pièce mais je vais y aller mais alors
passé il était en vacances à megève il
arrivé voilà il avait l'air en forme
il s'est remis de sa séparation d'avec
judith parce qu'elle était là la semaine
dernière bell a l'air de s'être bien
remise et je trouve ses racines dans la
sueur lui aussi sonné je troll là bas
[Applaudissements]
franchement c'est pas mal calcul une
métairie à majeur sinon à 24 il me
demande si on peut aller chercher une
baisse de secours chez moi catherine
mais si je donne le code comme je fais
une autre émission chez moi me donne le
code catherine c'est mort c'est dommage
que philippe de gaulle soit partie
hommage à madame je n'aurais qui fait
faire philippe de gaulle nous sur la
tête des valeurs de gauche c'est sûr
donc judith godrèche et hey lalala
semaine la semaine dernière elle avait
l'air d'avoir assez bien appris sa
séparation d'avec dany boon ça allait
nous et tant mieux oui dany ça va aussi
et j'ai l'impression que les rabatteurs
pour un non alors il ya aussi un coffret
qui va sortir avec ils s'aiment ils 66
minutes voilà avec pierre il se fait
engueuler non mais tu vas les caméras
avec caméra oui un coffret qui sort avec
kit somme ils se sentent eux mais voilà
c'est ça la saga complète tu penses tu
fais quoi michel quand tu pars tout le
temps à los angeles comme ça alors moi
je prépare un film j'ai acheté les
droits d'un livre qui s'appelle pitch
était caroline bon groupe je le connais
voilà c'est bien sûr et on voudrait
faire un film inspiré de ce livre attias
faire un film sauvez le pitch peut-être
alors tu vas venir le pitch est ici un
max obligatoire oui alors je n'étais pas
à la télé ce que je pourrais couper les
moments où j'ai l'air con quand je te
regarde comme ça jamais l'air con c'est
vrai oui c'est une idée que tu te fais
tu m'impressionnes souhaitait pas la
télé tu dirais quoi du décor de cette
émission
franchement il ya un truc que j'aime
beaucoup c'est la veste mais vraiment ou
pas je suis sincère je trouve que c'est
[Applaudissements]
non un petit truc si je manque un tout
petit truc je vais la signer way up
ouais
au second quart d'heure
[Applaudissements]
la clarté est ce que valérie peut venir
là valérie sa part comment cela pose pas
vraiment ouais je crois que là je suis
comme ça pour un long moment
est ce qu'on peut faire valérie un des
lingettes les logettes la revient avec
des lingettes valérie ge continue
interview de madame laroque
je termine ici alors je n'étais pas la
télé tu aurais quoi comme problème à me
raconter je sais pas ce qu'il ya eu dans
le ciel les armes et caetera que les
gens qui étaient un peu fragiles sont
allées très très très mal ouais j'avais
plein de coups de fil de gens qui
allaient mal et ça m'a vraiment inquiété
voilà c'est ça les problèmes ont
finalement laissé jean phlippe un peu en
ce moment lâchement si la période de
l'année
bachy non plus n'est pas comme si
c'était ça oui et puis comme je suis
maintenant entre les deux c'est quand je
reviens je sens plus ces choses parce
que j'ai pas subis tu vois toutes les
pressions ici et je trouve que parfois
c'est très lourd
et si je trouve que les gens sont plus
flipper enfin aux états unis en france
c'est différent ils sont très fines
bulles sommes pas d'accord avec vous je
ne peux pas chanter cause de bushmills
non mais les gens n'ont plus le moral
il ya eu quelque chose ou est de 12 je
trouve un truc les gens ont pu la pêche
non qu'est ce qui se passe là-bas irp 1
4i dit miley dans la loge vip d'accord
ok je viens à système choisi votre
ordinaire ici j'espère que ta famille un
costume non non c'est oui mais je sais
aussi comment des quotas m c'est par
amour un jouet thierry
oui tu es un chic type pensée pour moi
ça y est
[Applaudissements]
il s'est enfui il s'est enfui à le janet
tiens si quelqu'un pouvait maîtriser
jamel debbouze personnage il qu'ils
soient posées à thierry thierry tu
m'entends je t'entends djamel comment tu
peux mettre des photos pareil sérieux
quoi qu'ils fassent
mais david valider la cua rien mauvaise
mise sur cette photo mais c'est le style
de la photo djamel troll aulas le centre
t'apprendra à dire que mon spectacle
n'est pas intéressant bouffon et pour
être sûr de ne rien rater
le in a l'habitude abonnez vous je
m'étais un peu ce bleu